what are your thoughts on some of the
moves they were made this year there's
some big ones slight the Fox got tough
to cut this out that's where they're not
playing really well but this what I
expected out of them
Devon thanks a lot for joining us Bob
thanks for having me
good luck moving forward we'll be back
after this nine points 6 rebounds a
couple of steals for Randall his box
explodes to the rim and was able to
wedge that home after the ridiculous
crossover this is where he's going to be
the most successful shakes one leg goes
the other finishes at the rim beautiful
quick now watch this little given going
a beautiful read by temple and Boyd
Guerin foxes explodes to the rim
Demetrius Jackson no chance
Fox almost jumps into him
[Applause]
left you have a timeout left that it's
Darren Fox Fox clubbing tanana me stop
see pops to get the Kingston possession
and then watch Fox you have no
hesitation the air and gets to the paint
splashes one down hadn't made a shot out
there all night but says hey I'm a good
shooter
not not wanting down oh well there's
Terry's version of a pair of shots
better than no shine now posted with the
forum o'clock box is gonna have to
create box
[Applause]
[Music]
dear fox will pop aunty
[Applause]
the Kings first-round draft pick taken
fifth overall with a
to finish the half here on NBC Sports
California Kings with the 6147 leave
just to pressure the basketball you know
it's these similar and again I know ones
are cookie you can look at box climb the
ladder and top boy oh boy the Aaron Fox
with a pretty move to the baseline I
watch him just explode up a couple of
bucks think they can get to it but he is
up and done and there he has to hang on
to protect himself there so a very
different circumstance
here's Chandler the lead how about that
hustle by cauley-stein to break that up
state this year to Willie cauley-stein
the hustle well
[Music]
Kings diamond is this let the lead
dwindle box all the way look at him go
fear and [ __ ] oh boy beautiful full
length of the court move and it's 52 46
[Music]
[Applause]
NBA basketball the 20 year old comes
flying through the air there in South
Florida and gives the King still aid oh
boy Evers it down bogey
steps away off-balance goes up the air
oh my goodness to hand jump fella
get up with your red shoes on the Aaron
Fox and Bogdanovich thought he had it
and look at how close that comes but Fox
comes flying through the air we just saw
it again the Aaron fox gets in and
champs at home boy
look at this bogey pulls up the Aaron
man anticipation jumps up to five to
shoot Costa and then box two to shoot
Fox the Aaron Fox has 20 points from the
basket
Thomas and hope that if it's knocks it
away big turnover
box
107 104 now there's a difference on the
clock of three seconds do you foul here
do you played straight-up offense the
watch poked out of it spoke the ball
away right there from Isiah Thomas you
know really the just the length of bogey
pulled Isaiah and how about the Aaron
Fox I mean again just showing you that
amazing athleticism jumping over the top
of Julius Randle giving Randle some of
his own medicine
that's a mistake my Isaac got inbound
got a hurry
[Applause]
because it again the Aaron Fox really
clock running down the Aaron knows he
has to make something happen
this floater they were down by seven at
the end of one and a big deficit here oh
nice jumper by Fox with 0.2 that gets us
to the break he has six points and at
the half here in Denver
it's the Nuggets three seconds left
two-point game
no timeouts here's Fox it's his game
Darren Pop's can he do it one more time
ever go
he's a special that you're going to see
well-defended the body control look at
all the heat players have a shot at the
balls but da Hearns able to keep his
focus again breaking down the Defense
look at the heat come on him the hang
time there the difference gets it up
soft what an amazing play we've seen it
many times
clutch man the Aaron 3:25 we met in here
in the opening quarter from Sacramento
box you know like NBA basketball you
want to talk about acceleration due to
saw it from thierryd box meadow
[Music]
is the definition of a blue telling you
read WWE wrestling win a bottle pop out
the air and fox beating the shot clock
with the floater in the lane and Fox now
with his first basket start for D Aaron
Fox these got two points two assists
Randle leading the Lakers but they got
the lead offensively just about to get
to the turnovers get out note before
like that right there
man a steal and that will be the dunk by
Fox and a kingless on top 35 34 right
here nice little swing here and gets his
hand in the passing lane takes it down
and throws it down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
how about this
about box twisting weaving firing and
dinner now box teeing up Casper's boxed
behind a box crossing moving off the
glass beer and socks ow boy you don't
like that you know like kings basketball
from Kentucky has 10 good first quarter
in the books
29 28 Memphis your hands make sure you
protect the ball as much as possible as
you see you stand turn the ball over
alright numbers and there it is how
about that healed and Fox playing catch
[Applause]
we talk about electricity look at that
move and packbow least I know I can be a
basketball to Fox 5th put a clock on it
it's Twix right down the lane watch out
I'm ducking with it already
oh my goodness Wow yeah go bear put your
hand up for now only DeAndre as he came
off the floor through the upgrades you
really can't have a better guy than that
there's Fox and he Dow makes it 65 34
cycle a little left-hand dribble right
hand spin in the right hand box with a
steal
bucks now on over crop guys can do that
and the earrings box electrifying
everyone here that would be a solid look
at that put some cheese and bacon on
that burger
Oh baby earth box nicely done
left-handed scoop Pass just throw it up
fully handed appears down a two second
spots to the lane Oh
Deana man he showed romani was gonna
shoot it say I'm getting to the paint
baby
box Karen fog like I said grant that's
the difference right there Friday that
they have Mogambo gana [ __ ] and I'm on
Shumpert boxes they're gonna need it
and there's box banking at home it's
kinda like Brent oh my goodness did we
just see pops jump up and block that
shot by Jackson to get it done inside
think you got it point-blank thank you
very much we're going the other way
look at mr. Fox up above 210
[Applause]
how about the Aaron Fox right here grant
he is feeling all Michael Jackson just
beat it baby oh goodness gracious and
those are the type of plays that get the
King started to fans are standing on
their feet now keep that play in mind if
things turn around here in the second
quarter
Darren Fox it's for the guy with the
ball right now but there's what ws4 says
yes he is leaving and guess what he now
has two parts
taking it up top look at this grin
turning the corner up top woman I do I
deliver baby lot of standing around here
they give fox a little space and he
scores at the pusher we got to wrap him
up 108 103 basketball the lane look at
this I use my speed little spin cycle
put the kiss mr. [ __ ] delivers won't
thirteen four five level contact here
ten on the clock box box spinning fox
into the lane you know what keeps
basketball oh boy we'll go the other way
Jackson three on two
box box Oh if you don't like that you
know like Kings basketball the Aaron Fox
just don't jump this what they say yeah
yeah a little taunting six to seven
hundred threes a day you put that
together about 45
steal now not a good start to this
corner but look at that block by Darren
Fox and somebody's jumped you see get a
speed together and then let me beat it
to the chute box sees it beats the
caucus-goers slithery box right there
hits right through and delivers with a
layup and if you're a team player and
you want to get a foul go through that
when Harry jobs with a nice little push
shot from Darren cops
[Applause]
but the ends the first half with the
Kings leading five for the ball the
process it's about to be the Derek Fox
show
it was a very difficult fast let's take
another beautiful pass by foxes you're
right some so get them to do you think
knock down some pressure shots like so
turning the corner what defense my buddy
hield
at the Aaron Fox oh boy well with the
contest
listen
third the all the way over here great I
love it and here he is speaking of
defense in a steel tell me about it mr.
Fox force five with the lead
[Music]
eight lead changes ten ties box goodbye
Shira slam dunk contest only waiting to
give him here to give him
gonna have to hurry here box beach to
fly boy was that close
what to pass out by Willy and the clock
running down here's the air
[Applause]
basketball beautiful steal their D Erin
the steps in the passing lane bouts a
major women women's lemon and Jim
box box spinning
[Applause]
full length of the court move bite the
Aaron Fox half with 14 points five
assists and you can see that the ball
was can't expect them to shoot the same
percentage movie as they did in the
first half which was incredible
oh what a pass how about the Aaron Fox
getting that ball I had the buddy here
and creativity on the block
the second time you seen this right here
though you haven't seen this one before
that was just right on the money to put
a year opportunity to shoot the
three-ball instead watch the challenge
and then what's kind of breaks also be
our bow that's the red type right what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content